près de trois mois après le coup de
force du président tunisien sayed
l'opposition continue de dénoncer un
coup d'état constitutionnel
dans son viseur les mesures
exceptionnelles mises en place par
l'homme fort du pays et l'absence aussi
d'une vision claire pour sortir de la
crise politique et économique
à tunis plusieurs membres de la société
civile et de l'opposition ont lancé un
mouvement citoyen il appelle au retour à
un fonctionnement normal des
institutions et à des élections
anticipées
la correspondance de bassam chez miche
cahill sayed dans la ligne de mire du
mouvement citoyen contre le coup d'état
la tête de ce collectif l activité avoir
ben barek qui a annoncé ce lundi le
lancement d'une initiative démocratique
dont l'objectif est de définir les
contours d'une sortie de crise politique
fervent opposant à kayes ayed l'ancien
leader du mouvement en douze tours n'a
dénoncé un coup d'état opéré le 25
juillet dernier une violation de la
constitution et une instrumentalisation
de la crise sanitaire mais aussi
économique et politique désormais il
souhaite briser le silence et contredire
le bien fondé de l'initiative
présidentielle par un programme
s'appuyant sur des élections anticipées
et un dialogue national seule issue
selon lui à une sortie de crise durable
écouter une proposition pour sortie de
crise qui s'articule essentiellement sur
les élections présidentielle et
législatives anticipées la tunisie vit
depuis trois mois maintenant une crise
politique majeure et dans toute
démocratie quand une nation passe par ce
genre de crise le retour aux urnes le
retour à la souveraineté populaire à la
parole du peuple est nécessaire nous
pensons que maintenant les tunisiens et
les tunisiennes ont un droit inaliénable
à choisir leur sortie de crise il s'agit
d'un retour provisoire du parlement pour
des missions bien spécifiques et
ponctuels de la mise en place d'un
gouvernement de salut national pour
pouvoir
négocier une sortie de crise financière
avec nos partenaires étrangers parce que
le gouvernement actuel est un
gouvernement illégal en constitutionnel
et puis le troisième point c'est
d'ouvrir réellement un débat
un dialogue national stratégique sur les
questions stratégiques
y compris la question économique est le
modèle économique et social mais aussi
les réformes politiques et électoraux
électorale que la tunisie doit opérer
pour jaguar benbarek et la politique
menée depuis le 25 juillet par le chef
de l'état n'est autre qu'une violation
des droits de l'homme notamment ce qui
concerne le recours à un tribunal
militaire contre des civils les
interdictions de voyager pour les
personnes soupçonnées de corruption ou
encore à l'impossibilité de manifester
le mouvement citoyen contre le coup
d'état a lancé un appel à manifester le
14 novembre prochain afin de défendre
les libertés fondamentales et exigé un
retour aux acquis démocratiques issues
de la révolution 2011